Marvel's own God of Mischief-centered series
"Loki" just wrapped up its freshman season,
and fans have loved the time-bending thrill
ride.
Nicely connected to other films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe, set after the events of
"Avengers: Endgame," "Loki" adds additional
layers to the already complex world of heroes
and villains, and the season finale reveals
just enough information to get fans excited
about "Loki" Season 2.
The sixth and final episode of Season 1 finds
Loki and Sylvie reaching the Citadel at the
End of Time, and by the end of the episode,
they meet a major Marvel villain: the enigmatic
He Who Remains, a variant of Kang the Konquerer
whom Sylvie ends up murdering after shoving
Loki through a portal.
Perhaps more surprisingly, one of the loyal
subjects to He Who Remains is identified at
the very beginning of the episode, and it's
a reveal many fans had theorized about since
the start of "Loki."
One of the newer characters introduced to
the MCU in "Loki" is Miss Minutes, an animated
anthropomorphic clock who serves as both an
assistant and mascot of the Time Variance
Authority.
Her sweet southern drawl and emphasis on manners
and rules may seem wholesome at first, but
many fans had a lingering feeling that she
isn't as innocent as she appears.
And as it turns out, those fans were correct.
In the first few moments of the Season 1 finale,
Loki and Sylvie are greeted by the creepily
cheerful Miss Minutes, who reveals her loyalty
to He Who Remains and her behind-the-scenes
workings with the TVA.
While each "Loki" episode usually sends the
internet into a frenzy anyway, this final
episode lit up social media even more thanks
to its big reveals.
Tons of fans took to Twitter to joke about
how creepy Miss Minutes was in her initial
jump scare, likening her to a horror movie
monster.
One Twitter user wrote that they didn't see
the Miss Minutes reveal coming, though there
have been fan theories about her true evil
nature floating around the internet as early
as June, according to sites like Inverse.
Whether you saw this reveal coming or not,
the Season 1 finale of "Loki" has opened the
doors for many more exciting adventures in
Season 2, and we can't wait to see what happens
next.
After the reveal that Miss Minutes is actually
an important henchmen to the two Big Bads
of "Loki" — Kang and Renslayer — fans
were left shocked that this cheerful, animated
character was a bad guy in disguise.
However, Miss Minutes is still a pretty fascinating
character, thanks to her top-notch animation
and Tara Strong's excellent vocal performance
— and since the MCU loves bringing back
popular characters, it's definitely possible
that this cute TVA mascot may pop up in future
Marvel films and television shows.
According to an interview on Marvel's own
website, Miss Minutes was a favorite amongst
the show's creators as well as its fans, which
meant that the creative team behind "Loki"
cooked up ways to keep her as involved in
the narrative as possible.
Director Kate Herron revealed,
"Early on in the scripts, we all were definitely
united on, 'We've got to keep Miss Minutes
in the story somehow.'"
Head writer Michael Waldron agreed, saying,
"She was a really fun way to deliver some
pretty heady exposition.
There's something sing-songy and sort of non-threatening
about [the way she talks].
But yet, when it turns, and when she becomes
evil, suddenly it's really scary."
In fact, Miss Minutes originally had even
more to do, as Waldron explained, including
a daring fight scene — which, sadly, hit
the cutting room floor.
Waldron told Marvel that the show's writers
crafted Miss Minutes as a character that would
serve as,
"That devil on the shoulder and trying to
tempt both Loki and Sylvie.
It was fun that you got a sense of there's
something a bit more sinister going on here
with her."
He also revealed a scene that ultimately never
came to pass:
"We always had a version where [Loki and Sylvie]
kept meeting her at the Citadel.
At one point, we had a fight scene with Miss
Minutes in the Citadel; we had all kinds of
stuff [for her]."
The first season of "Loki" is streaming in
its entirety on Disney Plus now.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.